[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
rex chapman turner sports college
basketball analyst former kentucky star
twitter legend and his show the weekly
show rex chapman premieres this monday
on cnn plus new episodes will stream
every monday did you get recruited by
coach k at duke
no they knew i couldn't get in
how did they know that
they probably just saw me do an
interview
[Laughter]
did north carolina
i vis i visited carolina i loved
carolina growing up i visited uh
carolina kentucky louisville
georgia tech another place i couldn't
get in as a favor to craig neal who
played on the team then uh but yeah no i
love carolina dean was the guy i was
just talking about this to uh some
buddies the other day
when i was growing up and maybe when you
dean smith was the guy like he was
and to like to my son who's 29 coach k
is the guy
um
i just can't
can't believe he's retiring i kind of
hate it
but do you remember did you go to north
carolina and you were in dean smith's
office
yes sir uh i was uh i was
i remember young roy williams uh was the
main recruiter uh he he had just gotten
into coaching and he and dean flew to
owensboro kentucky
to pick me up i flew back with them to
carolina they had
jeff lebo
brad daugherty
joe wolf
kenny smith
they had a really nice squad i had a
great visit um
just probably wasn't going to leave the
state
but do you look back and go would it
have been better for me to leave the
state instead of staying in house where
you were
you were a legend in the state of
kentucky and the pressure was probably
pretty immense that maybe if you'd gone
to carolina would it have changed things
for you
i don't know i have no idea um i do know
this that given what i've gone through
i'm not sure if i'd have gone somewhere
else
that that place would have welcomed me
back with open arms like
uh kentucky did and the state and the
university uh after some of my issues so
i don't really second guess that uh
kentucky's an amazing school it's been
great to me i love the people there um
i don't know about the woodas and kudas
louisville louisville was really my
my only other school that i
truly considered and i grew up loving
daryl griffith
um denny chrome that whole thing dr
duncan
dr duncan stein i mean that that team
who was it bobby turner was he
no i well you know what they had uh dr
duncan stein they had the mcrae brothers
rodney and scooter poncho wright wiley
brown had the thumb
missing thumb yeah
yeah what a what a team and they got up
and down the court they were also
proximity wise louisville was about only
about an hour and a half from owensboro
where i grew up where kentucky is about
two and a half away
how did north carolina get here
wow uh you know it's interesting i
you know i did some of the tournament
stuff uh for
for tnt
how was that experience by the way it
was awesome it was fantastic yeah you
know
it beats working
so it was great um
but i saw duke play the first game of
the season against kentucky in new york
in the garden and duke was so much
bigger
uh that
i thought this team
this team has to be in the final four at
some point
i completely forgot about all of that
once i started looking at the brackets
that being said i think
carolina's here because they're big they
are huge they've got a big team
this matchup is crazy you know i can't
imagine i can't believe this is the
first time these two programs have met
in the tournament
but what a beautiful matchup
i love roy williams i love hubert davis
i
if nothing would make me any happier to
see hubert davis win it his first year
out
i'm rooting for coach k though i really
am
what hasn't he earned enough got enough
nope
i mean shouldn't he share
he is johnny dawkins and those guys
willed him to one of his first final
fours this team is willing him now uh to
this final four and
if you'd have told me look we talked
about dean smith a little while ago he
had you know that's how kind of i
learned to watch basketball was watching
him coach k came in when that era of
basketball was still going on and look
at how he's adapted he's not only
adapted to
you know
the landscape of college basketball with
the one and done and all that
but
i remember a few years ago jabari parker
playing for duke just came down and
launched one no passes just launched one
and i'm thinking in my mind he's coming
right out k's jerking him out nope let
him keep playing so there's some things
you just have to let go now and he's
done that yeah i want we're talking to
rex chapman i'm watching a lot there's a
lot of bad shooters in college
basketball rex
i was built for this this era
bad i invented bad shots
[Laughter]
you might have been better now
that might have been don't have to play
defense at all come on no but i'm
watching this and
you know i like villanova
you know jay wright is a wonderful coach
bill self has done it again with a team
that probably doesn't have a legitimate
star there
we're investing more in the coaches
probably than we ever have
now hubert davis is the outlier but
still he has the pedigree and that
franchise does
is that what college basketball is i i
liken it to you're either 18 years of
age or you're 23 years of age it's
either you're one and done or you're a
fifth year senior
yeah i think we we all have to get used
to changing our uh our
lens of college basketball and what that
means players are getting paid now just
get used to it they're pr they're
professional players or semi-pro players
um i got no problem with the coaches
making money i do have a problem with
you know now we see the transfer portal
and i know people are upset about it but
come on this is a system you guys have
in place
now guys can basically guys who want to
be traded can get trade
well the coaches the coaches have been
in the transfer portal forever and and
that's my point
i'm fine with the coaches making the
money but they may need to sit out for a
year if they go just up and break their
contract and go somewhere else that's
not right especially when the players
couldn't do that that's definitely not
right it's never been right
tell us about the new show on cnn
well apparently they found something to
do with me dan i know you and i talked
months ago and you said nobody knows
what to do with you
that is true yeah i talked to rex and
his agent and they're like what do we do
with rex i go i don't know
i don't know i don't want that pressure
to try to do something with you
you know and i got some really good
advice from you from rich eisen from
some people who know some things in the
business and you know the main thing was
rex don't let them do anything too
televisiony you know you're i'm not a
host i can't do what you do i'm not a
play-by-play guy that's a whole
different set of
skills uh
so
really my show is just me sitting down
talking with people i can tell you a few
of the people that we've had on on our
first episode on monday it'll be jason
sedakis i went over to london and
interviewed him we had a great time just
sat at their little
their bar that they go to in the show
and uh for an hour and just had a
terrific conversation i've interviewed
ben stiller that'll come up on another
one kevin love
a terrific conversation with kevin love
who i had never really we had never met
each other
and we talked a lot about mental health
so i'm excited i don't like anything
that i do whether it was basketball or
this or any i hate watching myself they
forced me to watch some of it
it's not bad they made you look good
they made me look
what they can do with editing and post
post uh
production amazing with a team of people
was just a team of people
jason sudeikis at college basketball did
you talk about his uh college basketball
career
yes and it's fantastic uh you know
because i i don't want to give too much
away but
i tell people that like with allen
iverson allen if you go up to allen tell
him you love him as a basketball player
he said well he'll say well i'm a
football player you should have seen me
play football in jason's mind he's a
basketball player
you know on his snl you know beginning
of his snl career you know he's out on
the playground here in new york shooting
hoops
he played seriously took it seriously
did drills the marovich drills all that
stuff decent high school player went to
play in college that's what he wanted to
do yeah so we get into that a lot of
other good stuff and uh i'm just excited
about it
uh
social media roughed you up with the
pete gillen uh rest in peace
[Laughter]
i'm thrilled pete is alive i i am too i
am too but rex i'm watching it live
and i go
rex can't be on drugs again like rex you
can't do this to me
he can be you know no
he could be but i'm watching i'm going i
think he just said pete gillen was dead
and then i thought maybe you had god
sham god dead
and i thought you're killing everybody
that's what the guy said on the set we
went to break and seth said did you say
r.i.p
i said yeah and he goes
and he goes well i think he's alive i
said oh
[Laughter]
and i said i'm thinking skip prosser
that's who i'm thinking of and who they
both coached at xavier when i was
growing up uh but that was it um have
you talked to me dylan
they sent me a
friend of his took a picture sent it to
me put it on twitter i sent back great
pete happy to know you're alive buddy
of course when he dies they're going to
say hey rex
yeah yeah yeah hope you're happy
i'm just preempting the sadness
how do you how do you do because you're
busy on twitter
how do you react when you're the subject
of twitter
twitter's not real
twitter's not real life man i i've
i people come at me on twitter all the
time
nobody does it in person i see people
out in the street all the time nobody
says a damn thing twitter's just a
twitter's just kind of fun you can't
take it too seriously it's not real i uh
i saw somebody made a comment about you
looking like scott van pelt
but he i have the look it's he took it
from me
andre again took it from me they said
you look like scott van pelt if scott
van pelt
owned a chocolate factory
it's so good and what's funny about that
too is scott and i scott and i get
stopped i get stopped in the airport all
the time people go svp sometimes i'm
like no sometimes i'm like yeah and i'll
find scott van belt let him go on their
way
and i know scott gets the same thing hey
great great to talk to you and uh good
luck on monday and uh thanks for joining
us bud
anytime dp thanks to all the guys there
hello and goodbye that's rex chapman
turner's sports college basketball
analyst and uh former nba star his new
show rex chapman premieres monday
april 4th on cnn plus new episodes we'll
stream every monday